we dream about you know having a little
bit of a farm one day and these are the
work years the gravy years are to come
so did difficulty balancing career and
family dr chris pratt and on affairs
apart I mean Anna definitely felt the
pressure of being a couple in Holland
yeah no doubt the jealousy the tabloids
and on actually details her struggle and
a new unpublished memoir and tonight
he'll what Anna was ready to reveal
before her marriage to Chris crumble
don't love it did I have a partner you
know and then I get to you know we get
to celebrate him yes on his upcoming
book unqualified was written before they
announced their split on a rice that
Pratt's presence grounded her and her
insecurities Chris actually wrote the
forward to the book saying quote she is
fierce and very loyal she rarely
punishes people but when she does it's
powerful and terrifying and when it's
over it's really over Entertainment
Weekly was sent an early version of the
book and reports on a rarely criticizes
Chris and praises has many acts of
kindness towards her he wrote poems and
letters by hand from international
locations sent flowers to the set of mom
every Friday before the show taste and
showered her with unexpected gifts she
was married to actor Ben Indra when she
met Pratt on the set of take me home
tonight Chris Pratt has been the easiest
person to have an on-screen romance with
because he's so gregarious he's such a
guy's guy she then divorced her first
husband and eloped with Chris and Bali
after a friend's wedding on the island
the books publisher confirms to et that
honor writes quote but in that Chris the
most striking thing about him was that
he knew how to be happy it made me
realize that being with someone who was
well-liked and popular actually made me
happy Faris admits to sometimes feeling
jealous of Chris's female co-stars like
Jennifer Lawrence but says she learned
to befriend and compliment them instead
of stirring up any kind of drama Lana's
book is scheduled to be released
in October